I think Google glass could be an
incredible technology.
Um,
one of my Grad students,
it's working at the lab is working on a,
uh,
simultaneous subtitle,
translation application for movies.
So you could go into a movie and be a
Spanish speaking person and you could go
into an English language movie and it
would show you the subtitles on the
Google glass while you're watching the
movie.
That to me would be very cool.
And if we could do it in seven or eight
languages,
that would be a fabulous application
for,
uh,
and,
and maybe even for people who are hard
of hearing you could,
you could do that and it has a little,
you know,
bone conductor in the back of the
things.
So you could feel the shake of the
buildings in an action movie,
but also see the English subtitles,
so to speak.
But that being said,
I also think that if I was at a really
interesting political dinner party,
say,
and someone had google glass on,
would I be as honest and open and you
know,
just completely loose,
especially after a bottle of wine as,
as I would if they didn't have google
glass on.
I'm not sure I would,
you know,
cause I wouldn't be sure we'll,
are they recording me or am I going to
get home?
I going to regret what I'm saying.
You know?
So that's,
that's an interesting question.